THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
I HATE TO SAY I TOLD YOU SO, BUT
I TOLD YOU SO.
IT'S ALL UNFOLDING EXACTLY AS I
SAID IT WOULD.
ON DECEMBER 6TH WHEN SENATE
ALLEGATIONS OF IMPROPRIETY, HE
>> BEFORE YOU JOINED THE MARCH
TO THE CASTLE TO CAPTURE THE
MONSTER, I HAVE A WORD OF
SUDDEN CASE OF FEVERISH MORALITY
BUT WHAT IT REALLY IS IS NOTHING
MORE THAN A POLITICAL
CALCULATION BY THE DEMS.
THEY HAVE TWO PADS TO DESTROY
THE PRESIDENT.
THE FIRST IS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
THE SECOND WAY THEY WILL TRY TO
DESTROY THE TERM PRESIDENCY IS
THE WAR ON WOMEN.
IT'S WORTH SACRIFICING FRANKEN
JUST LIKE THEY DID JOHN CONYERS.
THROW HIM OVERBOARD TO SAVE THE
POLITICAL TITANIC THAT IS THEIR
PARTY.
WHAT DOES THIS DO?
IT SETS THE PRECEDENT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO TRY TO DRIVE ROY
MOORE FROM OFFICE SHOULD HE WIN
THE ALABAMA SENATE RACE.
IN TWO THIS IS THE NEXT STEP IN
THE QUEST TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: AND LET ME TELL YOU,
COMPLAINTS BY THE SAME TRUMP
ACCUSERS THAT VOTERS HAD ALREADY
HEARD FROM BEFORE THEY ELECTED
OUR 45TH PRESIDENT.
CALLED ON THE PRESIDENT TO
RESIGN.
NEVER MIND THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS LONG DENIED THE CHARGES.
1:30 YEARS OLD AND THAT THERE
WAS NOTHING NEW IN ANY OF THEM.
IN A DANGEROUS CLIMATE WE HAVE
TODAY THAT THE LIBERALS HAVE
CREATED, ALLEGATIONS ARE ENOUGH
TO STRIP ANYONE, ESPECIALLY ANY
MAN OF HIS CAREER.
SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IS
THE DE FACTO LEADER NOW OF THE
CAT TRUMP CRUSADE.
HE REMEMBER HER VOICING SUCH
CONCERN FOR BILL CLINTON'S
ACCUSERS WHEN HE WAS APPEARING
AT HER FUND-RAISERS?
NEITHER DO I.
AND MORE TROUBLING, WOMEN WHO
WERE PART OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SEEM TO BE KIND
OF HEDGING THEIR BETS.
ON SUNDAY AT U.N. AMBASSADOR
NIKKI HALEY HAD THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND UP FOR THE
PRESIDENT, REALLY STRONGLY AND
CALL OUT THIS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED HYSTERIA.
INSTEAD, SHE KIND OF TOOK A PASS
INSTEAD, SHE KIND OF TOOK A PAS
PASS.
>> WOMEN WHO ACCUSE ANYONE
SHOULD BE HEARD.
THEY SHOULD BE HEARD AND THEY
SHOULD BE DEALT WITH.
AND I THINK WE HEARD FROM THEM
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION AND I
THINK ANY WOMAN WHO HAS FELT
VIOLATED OR FELT MISTREATED IN
ANY WAY, THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO SPEAK UP.
>> Laura: AND WOMEN WHO SEE
THEMSELVES AS PRESIDENTIAL
MATERIALS NEED TO BE HEARD MOST
OF ALL.
TODAY, NBC'S MEGYN KELLY IN WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A NEW DAILY FUTURE
SHOWCASED ANOTHER OF THE OLD
TRUMP ACCUSERS.
>> I DEMAND THAT HE IS SUBJECTED
TO AN INVESTIGATION BY THE
ETHICS COMMITTEE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HOLD THIS MAN TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARD AND IF 16 WOMEN HAVE
COME FORWARD, THEN WHY HASN'T
ANYTHING BEEN DONE?
WHERE IS OUR INVESTIGATION?
>> Laura: IT'S CURIOUS, DON'T
YOU THINK, HOW THIS ACCUSER
ISSUED A CALL FOR AN
INVESTIGATION JUST AS 59 HOUSE
DEMOCRATS RELEASED A LETTER
DEMANDING A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I'M SURE IT'S ALL JUST A TOTAL
COINCIDENCE.
HERE'S THE REALITY.
WHILE ROY MOORE WAS STILL IN THE
HEADLINES AND THE #MeToo-ITUS
WITH ALL THE RAGE, THE LIBERALS
HAD TO MAKE THEIR MOVE.
IT GOT THE BOOMING ECONOMY,
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE RISING.
TRADE DEALS BEING RENEGOTIATED.
YOU HAVE TRUMP JUDGES GETTING
CONFIRMED.
THINGS ARE LOOKING UP FOR THE
IS IT.
BUT MY FRIENDS, DO NOT BE
BILL CLINTON, THE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT CRUSADE HAS NEVER
BEEN ABOUT PROTECTING WOMEN.
IT'S ABOUT TAKING BACK POWER BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
SO NOW THAT MUELLER'S
IMPEACHMENT REPORT IS AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT TAINTED AND THE
PRESIDENT IS SCORING SOME BIG
WINS, DAMS NEEDED CHUM IN THE
WATER.
THIS IS IT.
I SAY THEY LET THEM EAT THEIR
OWN IF THEY WISH.
BUT THEY CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO
KILL OFF THE POLITICAL
ADVERSARIES WITH UNPROVEN
ALLEGATIONS.
AND FEMALE POLITICIANS AND
ACTIVISTS SHOULD ALSO BE REALLY
CAREFUL WHEN THEY TAKE THIS
BECAUSE SOMEDAY, MAYBE, THAT MEN
MIGHT DECIDE TO TURN THE TABLES
ON THEM AND START LAUNCHING
THEIR OWN, MAYBE IT'S CALLED
#MenToo MOVEMENT.
IF YOU DON'T THINK IT COULD
HAPPEN?
JUST WATCH.
THEN WHO'S GOING TO BE LEFT TO
CALL FOR SOME MODICUM OF DUE